looking right now at Miami Beach looks
pretty good as Floridians brace for the
arrival of Hurricane Dorian it's likely
to strengthen to a category four before
it makes landfall early next week
Dorian could be the strongest storm to
hit Florida's east coast since Hurricane
Andrew that was back in 1992 former
Louisiana Governor Bobby Jindal knows
firsthand what it's like to prepare for
a hurricane he was a congressman during
Hurricane Katrina we all remember that
which destroyed much of New Orleans and
he joins us at the table good to have
you here governor morning thank you for
having me thank you
we're glad you're here you certainly
know what it's like to deal with
catastrophic issues we certainly hope
that's not the case in Florida but right
now it is tracking to be a category four
as they sit there and they're waiting
what's what advice do you have for the
governor there and the residents to
really sure well I look I'd say three
things and we did have two big
hurricanes my first six months just like
governor DeSantis is facing the first I
would say is you need to over prepare
you hope for the best yeah you prepare
for the worst look if you over prepare
and the hurricane is not as bad as you
feared if it goes somewhere else people
might criticize you but if you under
prepare then people's lives could be
lost I'll give you a quick example in my
home state we had a nursing home a
health care facility that didn't want to
evacuate they refused to evacuate the
storm was coming they didn't think was
going to come to them we parked high
water vehicles in the front yard without
telling them in the middle of the night
we get this panic phone call saying the
water's coming we got to get these
patients out we said look outside you
know the National Guard is there they're
ready to evacuate your patients we've
got everybody out safely but weren't you
annoyed by that because you kept saying
that people leave there's always
somebody that says I'm not going well
look you said this best earlier we were
talking in Florida like in Louisiana
people have got a lot of experience with
storms unfortunately that can sometimes
lead to complacency yeah sometimes
people think it didn't hit me last time
it's not going to hit me this time the
second thing I would say in addition to
over preparing it's always better to ask
forgiveness not permission
sometimes the bureaucracy gets in the
way again I give you an example we had
commercial buses to help us evacuate New
Orleans they didn't show up in time they
kept telling us they were coming they
were coming
we actually got National Guardsmen some
of them who didn't have their commercial
driver's licenses
we got school buses we've got those
folks out there are many times where
FEMA they mean well but they can get in
the way they you may remember they were
telling people you can't go in the water
and rescue people without proof of
insurance and registration
cajun
didn't-didn't follow those rules they
saved a lot of people the third thing
and I would say this is the people of
Florida the first two were for a
government the third is for the people
of Florida you're the best first
responder for your neighbors and friends
the reality is look the local officials
the state officials of federal officials
are gonna do amazing jobs our first
responders will run towards danger not
away from it even when their own houses
are being flooded but if you've got a
neighbor if you've got a relative that
needs help
you're the best person to help that but
so get your family safe if you can help
a neighbor or an elderly relative please
do that the Cajun Navy the Volunteer
Force there in Louisiana on the subject
of response the Trump administration is
diverting 151 million dollars from FEMA
to border initiatives what do you make
of that look I think the important thing
is the resources need to be there for
Puerto Rico for Florida for any of these
states for Georgia for anybody that's
gonna be impacted by this storm I do
believe the resources will be there I
hope the Democrats and the Republicans
don't try to make this into a political
football storms aren't partisan there
were spon shouldn't be partisan so I've
got confidence the resources will be
there to respond to this storm and we
need to be vigilant to make sure they
are even without the hundred fifty 1
million look this president has no
problem spending money I wish he would
be more restrained and how he spends the
money our our tax dollars but I think I
think the money is going to be there let
me do say this as a state that benefited
from the state the country's generosity
after Katrina and Rita I do want to say
I think the people of Puerto Rico
they're American citizens they deserve
our ongoing support and help as well
speaking of this president in 2015 you
told our congressional correspondent
Nancy Cordes that President Trump was an
egomaniac and a narcissist how would you
rate his first term in office look I was
telling Gail earlier I voted for him I
ran against him I had low expectations
for my voted for him there are many
policy things I've liked I'd like the
fact that he cut taxes these cutting
regulations supporting America's energy
industry I like the fact he's appointed
conservative judges there are things I
don't like I know for example I do wish
I'd mentioned spending I wish that they
would look at its strengthening Medicare
and Social Security I think Republicans
can't only worry about deficits when
Democrats are in charge
I do support what he's doing with China
but I wish he'd bring our allies with us
like the European Union and others so
we're not doing that alone so there are
things I don't like but in all I do so
for many of his policies and again I had
low expectations I know understand
because this happens with a lot of
people who say these terrible things
during the campaign egomaniac and
narcissist
at the time you didn't think he was good
for the country how do you go from that
to voting for someone who you don't
think great question is is a good
actually I actually publicly endorsed
him in the Wall Street Journal I wrote
an op-ed that spring saying I don't
expect him to be the next great
statesman I didn't vote for him thinking
that all my opinions didn't suddenly
change yeah I voted for him for two
reasons I said one I think there he will
try to repeal Obamacare I think there
was a chance he'll try to appoint
conservative judges I don't know if he
will I didn't kill her what because I
know they're counting it down how do you
think he's doing now on policy I think
he's done better than I expected like
many of his supporters I wish didn't
tweet as much I wish he didn't go thank
you thank you right back